i'm back with a very important video
on how to stop frying your brain
with your cell phone now i've talked about this in
other videos but i wanted to do a series of videos
on something called emf and try to break it down
really really simple it's going to be a fairly
short video but i'm going to show you what i do
to minimize what's called invisible radiation so
emf what is it it stands for electromagnetic field
so what does that mean well you have an electric
component to it you have a magnetic field part
of it and you also have other fields of energy
radio frequencies and even microwaves typically
you think of microwaves being the microwave oven
but there's other things that will give you
microwaves including your cell phone the
problem is it's not regulated by safety
codes at this time so it's kind of like
at some point in time people started
smoking and smoking was considered
actually beneficial for you you also had ddt which
was considered beneficial you also had asbestos
which was considered safe and then you had sugar
which was considered beneficial at one time
and then years later they found out oh we didn't
do the safety testing on that long enough so
whoops sorry so we're going to put some regulation
in so right now unfortunately there's not a lot of
safety testing going on now let's first talk about
the electrical fields so you have all these little
electrons going through a wire that's called the
current going through the wire and the pressure
that's pushing this electricity is called the
voltage so it's the pressure from a power source
so the more pressure or more voltage the more
electrical field you're going to have on the wire
and so let's say for example you're trying to
sleep at night and right next to your bed you have
a light source you have your alarm clock you
have some other electrical devices and some
people might have the consideration that if they
turn the light off the electrical field goes away
well i want to demonstrate that it actually
doesn't go away unless you unplug the light at the
outlet on your wall because even though you turn
the light off at this level if you were to open up
this wire it would be hot or live in other words
there's voltage in that wire that is generating
an electrical field unless you disconnect it at
the wall and so there's different switches that
you can get you can plug it into the wall and
then plug your uh light into there so you can
turn things off at the outlet level so there'll
be less electrical current coming from these
wires next to your head while you're sleeping and
then you have magnetic fields so magnetic field
occurs anytime there's current flowing through
a wire and so there's a field that's generated
sometimes six to eight feet from that source
if it's a strong magnetic field and so magnetic
fields only occur if it's live if there's current
flowing through a wire so let me demonstrate that
so i'm on electrical fields right here and take
a look at these wires down here right these wires
are connecting to this light right here okay
now let's go ahead and turn off the light okay
look it this is still high the wire
is still high because there's voltage
in this cord so we want to turn it off at the
outlet or just unplug the light or other devices
next to your bed okay for the next
demonstration i'm going to turn it
to magnetic fields in order for something to
have a magnetic field you have to have current
flowing through it so we turned on the light
okay so we have the light right through here
you can see that it's pretty high
right now i'm gonna turn off the light
okay now i'm gonna i'm gonna
assess the the same cord
and it's not not very active if at all why
because the magnetic field only occurs if there's
current flowing through the wire if i turn it to
the electrical field it's high but not magnetic
so electrical fields have to do with voltage which
is the power that's pushing these little electrons
and magnetic field has to do with the fields that
extend beyond the current it's not the voltage or
the power it's just the electrons going through
it and then we get to something called radio
waves or microwaves and for that topic you have a
router you might have a cell tower that is sending
signals to your cell phone and so if your phone
is close to your head your brain you're going to
be getting exposure to microwaves not to mention
maybe some magnetic and electrical fields as well
so let me do a little demonstration with the cell
phone to show you all right so now we're going to
turn this all the way to radio frequencies okay
i'm going to get it close to my cell phone right
here you can see it's pulsing right because
we have this this uh the cell tower is sending
signals every so often okay so now i'm going
to actually make a call i'm going to call jared
so you can you can see that it's
pulsing like this so all this
microwaves are going right to your brain if
it's held up close to your skull now in the
future i'm going to do some other videos to show
you how to identify other sources of invisible
radiation using this tool right here i like
the tri-field emf meter model tf2 i have other
devices this seems to be very simple it's very
accurate and i'm going to show you what i found
with my power cables my up on my computer
the actual screen itself the wi-fi devices
the printer and so all these things are bathing
your body in these frequencies and if you're
sitting behind the computer like i do for a very
long time um it's not healthy so you're gonna have
to minimize the exposure and find out where it's
coming from so with this device you can measure
the radio frequencies the electrical fields as
well as the magnetic fields very very simply and
i'll be doing more videos on that if you're
interested in getting one of these i'll put
a link down below and you can check it out i
don't get any kickbacks or anything like that
and so it's a really good device and you can
go around your house and just find the sources
of uh where you're being affected now getting
back to the cell phone what are you gonna do
well there's a couple things first thing is
that uh try to talk with the speaker on so it's
not connected to your head but what i found was
this right here okay so now i have these earbuds
which are right here right got it plugged
into my phone and i still have it on radiation
so you can see that they're not really having
any effect definitely earbuds are the way to go
so we have earphones and a mic and it's called
anti-radiation air tubes okay they're headphones
with the mic emf protection you can look these up
i'll put a link down below on amazon um on the one
that i have but again i don't get any kickbacks
or any commissions but i just want you guys to
know about this so what's cool about this is
that there's just a tube between this source and
your ear so it gives you some space so you don't
have a direct electrical wire going into your ear
that's why i don't recommend the bluetooth devices
where you're sticking the ear now the sound pickup
is not perfect but it's doable so what you do is
you would put these in your ear and the problem is
that this is not going to connect into your cell
phone okay so you have to get an adapter and so
i got an adapter right here i'll put a link down
below which plugs into this 3.5 millimeter jack
then i can stick this into my cell phone so now
i can hold the source of the radiation over here
and not have it affect my brain now i am doing a
lot of zoom presentations all day long so what i
did is i got an adapter for that too so this is
what it looks like right here so this has a usb
and then i can plug this right here plug this in
the back of my computer and now i can actually
be on zoom and interact with people and so
no longer do i have to have those headphones
which actually make your head so tired and so i
found my energy greatly increased after getting
these this adapter and also these earphones so i
highly recommend it if you're on the phone a lot
i would recommend it for your kids if they're on
zoom doing the home school especially the younger
they are the more sensitive they're going to be
especially on putting electromagnetic fields into
your brain not a good thing so go ahead and try
this and comment down below and stay tuned for
more information about how to protect yourself
against emfs before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto and you want
to know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the u.s. hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help